what's going on guys welcome to another
Python tutorial in this tutorial I'll be
showing you guys how you can organize
lists in Python and I'll show you
specifically with a CSV since a lot of
people will be working with CSVs but
actually you don't have to do it just
with CSVs and really you don't even need
the csv reader to do any of this but for
the sake of showing it i'm going to go
ahead and show it anyways but i'm going
to show you both ways and then i'll just
show you how you can just sort a simple
list anything you're doing within
pythons
very very useful stuff so to keep it
simple we're going to just do the CSV
first so I'm going to go ahead and
import CSV it's just a CSV reader that
Python has you know pre-built but again
really reading see SBS is just like
reading any other file you don't really
have to use CSV at all we're going in
anyways and then import operator
operator is going to be the main man of
this mission and it's going to do the
actual sorting by the quote unquote
column that we choose so to start I did
make a sample data file and we just pull
it up real quick here it is and as you
can see we've got two quote unquote
columns the sample data is actually from
a text file so it doesn't have to be
even a dot CSV but it can be it's from
this text file and as you can see
neither one is neither column right is
ordered at all so we're going to use
that file so we're going to say sample
equals open and then sample data text
with the intention to read and then
we're going to go ahead and just so I
could show you the CSV reader is going
to say CSV one so it just doesn't
conflict with CSV up here equals CSV
reader and then we want to read a sample
and then we're going to go ahead and
tell it what the delimiter is so
delimiter equals comma since they are
comma separated now to sort this stuff
all we do is sort evils sorted and what
do we want to sort we'll
the CSV one and then we'll say what the
key is and the key to sort is going to
be operator dot item getter and then in
here you say what element of that each
array you want to sort by so for example
these are all the 0 with elements and
these are all the first if elements
first anyways 0 so that was sort by the
first column so to speak so we do that
set sort now we're just going to do a
quick for loop or each line in sort
print each line so now when we save that
run that come over here we and see wow
it did indeed sort by that first column
conversely we can always do the second
column run that and again this is all
jumbled up but this column is nice and
very neatly sorted pretty cool but again
like I said you don't actually have to
use the CSV reader the downside of the
CSV reader is your CSV reader is going
to require a at least in this in this
sense I don't know too much about the
CSV module I kind of don't see the point
of it personally because you could
instead open up the sample file split it
by new line and then split it by comma
so that's what I've always done
personally but at least in this form
it's going to expect of you to pass all
of the items through it as strings so
you couldn't really get away with
calling CSV Reader on like a list or
something like that but that's fine
because you don't need that at all so
here's another example so we're going to
say sample 2 equals and then we're going
to have you know old list and then we're
going to have some lists within our list
we'll just make it simple with three
items so we can do 5 6 and then 7 1 and
3 2 okay so neither column is sorted so
now sort doesn't have to be a CSV type
of file at all it could be sample 2
right so this is just you know if you
had maybe x and y coordinates
and you really wanted to organize your
x-coordinates to go linear in order this
would be how you would do it so again
we'll do this everything else lines up
so that's fine we can run it and you can
see that we've organized by the second
column since that's what we left in
there so let's go ahead and fix that and
make it the first column and we drag
this back over and sure enough you can
see that we are organized by that first
column so really neat stuff normally it
is shown with in CSV just because the
idea of it is you're organizing by a
column but as shown you don't need to
use CSV at all you can read every file
without CSV anyway so it's not essential
but sorting via quote-unquote columns or
elements in each little ray can be very
very helpful especially when you're
merging maybe two bits of data together
but you want to organize them either by
a date or something else this becomes
extremely useful so anyways hopefully
you guys found that interesting as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support in the subscriptions and
until next time